en el vídeo anterior vimos que la
compañía obtuvo un préstamo de un millón
del prestador uno con tasa variable de
2% mientras que la compañía ver también
obtuvo un préstamo de un millón del
prestador 2 pero con tasa fija de 8% y
las compañías llegar a un acuerdo en que
a le paga el 7% tasa fija a la compañía
ve con respecto al millón especulativo
quiero decir que jamás hay el
intercambio del millón así que ha de
pagar el 7% ave con respecto a ese
millón especulativo y ve en cambio le
paga la ifor más 1 por ciento del millón
especulativo cada periodo
así que vélez está pagando una tasa de
interés variable ahora lo que quiero
mostrarte en este vídeo es quiero que
veas el procedimiento numérico para
mostrarte que en efecto ahora la
compañía a tiene un préstamo con tasa de
interés fija mientras que la compañía ve
tiene un préstamo con tasa de interés
variable hicieron un intercambio de las
tasas que tenían sus préstamos ahora
recordemos en el período 1 para la
compañía
ellos pagaron un 7% en tasa de interés
variable un 7% que son 70.000 dólares 70
más no me lo mejor lo pongo de otra
manera lo voy a poner de esta otra
manera en el período 1 la compañía apagó
70 mil dólares 70 mil dólares al
prestador 1 pero aquí aquí que está
pasando la compañía no solamente le está
pagando al prestador 1 también está
pagando a la compañía ve ese 7 por
ciento del millón especulativo entonces
la compañía también le paga le paga 70
mil dólares que son 7 por ciento de un
millón del millón especulativo a la
compañía ve ave y ahora ve en cambio le
va a dar a la ifor más 1% entonces a
obtiene va a obtener obtener la
información por ciento en el período 1
25 por ciento entonces 51 por ciento son
6 por ciento 6 por ciento del millón
especulativo son 60 mil dólares que ve
le da
ahora si observamos bien aquí vemos que
está pagando el pago neto de a son
70.000 dólares dos veces menos los 60
mil dólares que recibe debe así que el
pago neto de a en ese periodo fue de 80
mil dólares y eso fue lo que pasó en el
período 1 ahora que pasó en el período 2
en p2p 2 tenemos que el eibar está en 4
% entonces la compañía le va a pagar al
iphone 4 por ciento más el 2% de su
préstamo así que paga 6% total paga 60
mil dólares al prestador 1 y recordemos
también el acuerdo el 7% le paga el 7% a
ve a ver si no lo pongo lo voy a poner
así le paga los 70 mil dólares a b y
recordemos que también recibe debe la
iwork más 1% entonces recibe debe haber
más un por ciento que es 4 por ciento en
este caso 4% más el 1% son 5 por ciento
5 por ciento que son 50 mil del millón
especulativos son 50 mil así que él
algo neto el pago neto de a en el
período 12 60.000 70.000 son 130.000
menos 50 mil son 80 mil dólares entonces
a a paga paga 80 mil dólares en el
período 2 y ahora nótese que en ningún
momento cambia lo que apaga tú puedes
cambiar la tasa de libor y verás que en
ningún momento va a cambiar esos 80 mil
dólares que a está pagando a esta hora
en una tasa fija y en cambio ve este en
el lado opuesto porque antes de pagar 80
mil dólares cada periodo y ahora
cambiará un poco veamos en el período 1
en el período 1 ellos pagan 80 mil
dólares de hecho en cada periodo así que
en el período 2 también le pongo aquí 80
mil dólares que paga la compañía ve y
recibe el 7 por ciento del millón
especulativo por parte de a entonces
aquí recibe 7 por ciento del millón
especulativos recibe 70 70 mil dólares y
recibe 70 mil dólares pero recordemos
que también paga life + 1 por ciento
entonces aquí en el primer periodo ellos
a 60 mil dólares entonces paga 60 mil
dólares y en el periodo 2 pagan pagan 50
mil dólares así que cuál es el pago neto
en el periodo o no el pago neto es de 80
paga 80 recibe 70 paga 60 por tanto el
pago neto es de 70 mil dólares y en el
período 2 ellos pagan 80 reciben 70
pagan 50 así que pagan 60 mil dólares en
el período 2 así tenemos entonces que a
está pagando una tasa fija de 8%
mientras que me paga una tasa de interés
variable